welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
Movie Channel and we are joined by
look at you
Michael Ball hey Michael Ball from this
solo one podcast is joining to talk
about the Orville
um we do have quite an interesting room
that I've heard in the last few days
that we'll talk about at the end of the
video if you could be bothered to hang
around that long
um but for now we're just gonna we're
gonna talk about our likes and loves and
hates from the show and season four
obviously
[Music]
Festival
Michael
when did you first come across the
Orville
okay so as a person who studies a lot of
current science fiction series I tend to
look at a lot of news sites and
something came along about was it 2017
it was near this at the same time as
Discovery coming along
as a show where they wanted to sort of
have something in the same vein as Star
Trek but in a more of a comedy thing
and I was thinking that it was going to
be What's that show
um the other sci-fi movie where it's a
comedy series Galaxy Quest that's it
it's very much and I thought well look
let's give it a go and I thought
yeah let's go go along with it and I
obviously saw the First episodes and I
was very interested so
um let me ask tell the question about
you what do you think about it when you
first heard about it
um so yeah I thought it was very much
um Family Guy in space yeah initially
um I I adored the first season I the
first couple of episodes in particular
you know getting the new ship call it
the Orville and I thought well he's
making a stupid joke and then realizing
why he'd called it that after obviously
the Wright brothers and everything
bloody clever
um and I I known he'd wanted to make a
Sci-Fi show for years he's a massive
geek
um he wanted to make a Star Trek show
and they wouldn't let him so he went
I'll make my own then and I just think I
I for a long time the most Star Trek
show on television was the Orville
um and obviously it wasn't about how it
changed but the first especially the
first few episodes it was more of a
general comedy show it was it was more
like red dwarfs what he says it was more
it it changed though this is what's very
interesting about the show it did change
yeah
I miss the humor because I love I think
Seth MacFarlane's humor I could say it
did set it apart
um Galaxy Quest to me was light-hearted
and yes it was a comedy it was a parody
of Star Trek
the Orville was more of a comedy it was
actually funnier I think we're getting a
TV series of Galaxy Quest
yeah I I don't get it I think we've got
a TV series of Galaxy Quest it's called
the Orville just really do that yes um
we'll talk about season four in a bit
obviously but
you know a lot of people said actually
they're the first season of the Orville
failed they said it didn't get very good
ratings
um which
it maybe didn't
um and because obviously at that point
it wasn't on Disney plus it wasn't a
streaming service it was on
um you know
um was it on Fox it was on Fox yeah
um so um or whatever wherever it was in
the United States
um and it didn't do great
um but they put it on Disney and the
ratings just went through the roof
because people it's one of those shows
that is golden for streaming services
and I keep talking about this on the
Channel streaming services love a show
that people watch yeah but what they
really wanted to show that people watch
over and over and over again
um that's why you don't get shows very
often like love island or something like
that on a streaming service something
that even though loads of people might
watch it once they're like but they
don't watch it again
um and you know so they love that's why
stream Services love sci-fi and they
love um crime dramas and things like
this because people will watch it
and we did that with the Orville
um so the first season was considered a
failure but really as soon as it was
just on the wrong thing yes I think we
started to see the humor
disappear a little bit in season two
um did you did you feel a tone
difference I I personally felt that the
actual humor started to actually
dissipate a bit in the first season the
latter half of the first season
um and the second season from the way I
remember it was that it it felt it was a
very clever transition
um and I this is what is so strange
about the show but in some ways it was
season two was
it was very very it was about 20 comedy
80 drama and the first season felt more
like it was about
what a six percent comedy 40 drama it
was a very clever transition
um but the way that did it actually kind
of worked because I kind of like the
humorous side of the first season
earlier episodes but I kind of liked it
more
when it became a show with its own
Universe great special effects great
characters in a way that I thought well
look okay it's Star Trek it's not Star
Trek but it's a similar vein it's got
more comedy but not too much comedy I
love comedy myself but I like the fact
that to me season two balanced out the
comedy and the drama just right
in season three in her New Horizons do
you feel that it maybe went too far the
other way into the theory that's a good
question
um potentially maybe yes it may be that
it went to a point where it kind of
aliens its own original premise of how
it was when it started
um
I guess it's down to individual
preference of humor
um yeah because there were still jokes
there was there were still there was
still jokes and the characters so I
don't mind it let me ask you obviously
you asked me what did you think about
the third season I think it did lose too
much of the humor for me it it it went
too serious
um I think about like the episode with
Malloy when he found the phone
um
that was quite a series and Malloy was
always sort of one of the main focuses
of the comedy so um and I know he saw
his character developed and stuff but
that episode for me was borderline
boring I I didn't I didn't particularly
love it but
the series as a whole was about the K
line attack
um so kaylorns were very very seriously
menacing in the third season when they
actually went all out and it was such a
clever thing with Isaac and his race it
was it was his race and how
um you know in before we'd see them in
that episode they were talked about but
they were properly featured I think
that's correct but when we finally saw
them they were pretty bad they were
pretty kind of like
um their version of the book in some
ways I thought that somebody said oh I
think of the ball but they just there
were mechanical minutes
if you had a species of datas
and they were that logical because they
weren't evil they were logical yeah you
are a risk you are a threat to us so
we'll wipe that threat out it's it's
logical
we got a load of woke nonsense people
saying shouting woke in the third season
but I'm just like
does my head in you know um I forget the
female character's name but you know the
pilot who's supposed to be the 3D thing
and she ended up saving the day in the
end
um very pretty pilot
um and it was sort of gonna oh she's
just brilliant everything she's a she's
a Mary Sue whatever they really call it
I suppose I
I saw skill I mean obviously uh a lot of
the current shows they do have what you
call workisms as an individual are you
bothered about it does it is it it's a
tough one because we are in a world now
where you have to have representation of
stuff but sometimes they go too far yeah
yeah if the storyline comes first
it doesn't bother me I mean writers have
always always tried to tell a moral
story or something like that in what
they work they try to put what they
believe in their work so if somebody is
homosexual and they're writing and
they're they've got things about their
you know the the Troubles of their
Community that's going to appear in
their writing the problem with that the
problem with that character again whose
name I've forgotten I'll put it in the
edit
um it was like nobody but I had an
eyelid when John Lamar all of a sudden
became a genius
you know and but she was a very clever
girl and so and people went crazy and
started chatting work I I felt that was
unfair some people that shout woke
they'll comments on my channel I'm sure
they do yours as well occasionally and
it's basically everything's woke
everything and like if you watch the
boys have you honestly you know you
could list a million shows off top of
your own
examples obviously yeah exactly yeah
but I mean obviously it's not just about
the workers for me I mean obviously
um the fact of the matter is that this
series is very clever because I remember
watching it
um at the same time season one was on of
that as he's a lot of Discovery now I
I'm with Discovery it's such a strange
show because now I'm watching it for the
perspective of what they've done since
obviously a lovely card I love Strange
New World I like social work I love
straight it's really good I'm not into
the animator but it's it's pretty good
I remember Watching Discovery and
remembering how much more I thought well
look searching Wells is one
that's Star Trek
Discovery isn't it it just feels like
it's it's like another Universe it
doesn't feel it's got the name of Star
Trek but it's important reasons in
particular mostly the fourth season
really the second season wasn't as bad
but the first season exactly it was far
too much influence from the Kelvin
timeline and trying to Blends it's
because people involved with that work
from working
um yeah exactly
was the one yeah exactly the obviously
know what I'm saying so
um when I watched the awful the early
episodes I was really thinking I'm gonna
see this is what I wanted to see with
Discovery you know why why was it that a
lot that perhaps not as like the comedy
level but the actual fact that it was
kind of like it was in space it was
um Stanley a lot of the episodes were
quite Standalone as well I mean positive
attitude of the future wasn't it where
his Discovery was very dark and very
negative yes but all was a positive look
at the future where Humanity was
actually trying to be its best it was
properly Gene Roddenberry Star Trek yes
the orbital has a lot of the corporates
a lot of Gene modern race stuff in that
sort of show I mean like it's more of a
comedy but it has that kind of
um
I don't describe it that kind of
embracing
Discovery and
um away in but more of a comedic side of
things at least in the early Seasons
with the humor coming away from the
series which is like I say there's not
as much humor in the in the last season
has it just become
too much like Star Trek to actually have
fourth season 50s and 60s is it
without the humor is there any real
point because we've got five seasons of
Star Trek on Paramount just watch that I
in some ways yes I I think to go into
the deep down
it does feel more like a Star Trek
copy
I think
but northern like Babylon 5 or other
side because I mean lots of sci-fi shows
are spaceship
you know but it's very very simple it's
a very similar premise isn't it it's
very similar about you want to ship your
your exploring you you encounter some
bad Races they inform they actually
create alliances against you then you'll
fight them but then another bad day
becomes your goodie to fight them but
very DS9 you know Dominion Kardashian
kind of feel but that was it's the kalon
it's the you know it it but
I don't know it's a very tough question
because
well Olivia I don't know let me get your
perspective then I'll ask for your
perspective what do you think I would
actually say there are certain episodes
of the Orville that if you pulled out
those actors and put in the Next
Generation actors and just did it
exactly the same with exactly the same
script yes
um it would be a Star Trek episode yes
um it's not just similar they're very
very similar I think about ones where
they um they found that race that was on
in that
um uh bio ship and it was um you know
like a ship that had been traveling
through but it was breaking it was
actually heading towards a star I think
and there was this whole community
living there that didn't know their
aboard a ship I'm like yeah no a Star
Trek the Next Generation
or something yeah I mean all over so I
do I do think
I but I think Seth MacFarlane is quite
aware of that and I do think he's tried
to bring it away but I think trying to
create a show that he loves he has just
made a Star Trek copy I don't mind it to
me it's almost like a it's a it's like
another spin-off of Star Trek but with
um a slightly different kind of it's
like a way out spin-off I mean would it
have been more unique if it had been
more of the comedic side of things from
season one I don't know I think I'd have
liked to have seen that come through but
the problem was I think some of the
complaints were that it was just Family
Guy in space now I personally look at
that and I love the drama elements I
always argue as rather when you've got a
drama that doesn't have humor and they
go oh it's gritty and realistic and I'm
like well it's not
um I've worked in several environments
that are very stressful and the first
thing that the people I work with do
when things are stressful is they make
very inappropriate jokes and they you
know they bring humor into it and
because It's A coping mechanism so I was
saying whenever you see a drama without
humor I was like that's not real life
people a particular maybe that's a
British thing that we take the piss out
of everything when things are bad the
worst things get the more you know the
darker the humor gets yeah we laugh you
know I've worked for the NHS I've worked
a lot of things where it's very very
stressful environment things like the
joke where they're trying to teach Isaac
practical jokes so he does that
practical joke it was Miss Potato Head
and puts a thing in his head they're all
laughing at it I love that I love that
that was really good so Isaac lobs his
leg off okay
but that was such a clever joke because
again it's told us something about Isaac
as well you know I'd like to have seen
more of that because that to be fair was
genius things were the mocklins and the
um the smoking and stuff like that again
it was just clever
um
but we saw we I think we have seen that
throughout the three seasons I just
think Seth MacFarlane's trying to be
more dramatic there is a question I have
to ask you that um I think that
um
most people would actually if they've
seen much as I've seen that every show
whether it be Star Trek Stargate
um the Orville there always are some
stories where there's almost like a
repetition there is always stories where
each franchise has something which is
similar is science fiction is strange
because it's a big big
field of
um storylines and ideas and philosophies
but
is for it it's not it is limited there
are
only certain ways to go and how many
stories can you tell in science fiction
well I mean they reckon there's only is
it like six stories really if you boil
them down
exactly yeah when you get them to the
absolute Basics you know there's like
Revenge love
um
and then everything else and everything
yeah everything else is just a variation
of those themes
but I think when you've got something
like the Next Generation that had 22
Episodes and seven seasons and then
you've got Deep Space Nine the same you
know whether you've got hundreds and
hundreds of episodes
um you know like start Stargate add over
220 episodes
there's only so many stories you can
tell and there's and you're going to get
but we've seen this before we've seen
how Stargate Universe was inspired by
Babylon it was so it was inspired by
Battlestar Galactica
um we've seen How Deep Space Nine was
possibly slightly
um creative people will see something
and they'll be inspired by it they'll
love something I think let's do our
version of that and that's just
human nature and which is why we do see
things that you think I swear I've seen
this show before with other actors
occasionally
um but the nice thing about sci-fi is
though that they can tell the same story
in a million different ways and you
don't necessarily know you're seeing the
same story
um and they can do Mysteries they can do
romantic episodes and they can do they
can they can basically do an episode of
every other TV show combined that's one
of the reasons why we love sci-fi so
much because they can do an action
episode they can do a rom-com they can
they can do anything whereas other
things you know Emmerdale is I'm sorry
American friends aren't going to know
Emmerdale but um a situation comedy say
you're very very walked into that
situation whereas a Sci-Fi is any
situation first of all there's loads of
rumors um I actually dropped a rumor um
oh God six or seven months ago now that
they were
um Disney we're talking Seth MacFarlane
and a couple of the other actors about
bringing it back for season four
um but actually there was a big
stumbling block or two
Seth MacFarlane is insanely busy
um particularly the Ted TV series he's
doing a movie he's doing a few other
things and um the budget the budget for
New Horizons was too high
um it's a very popular show but it's not
popular enough for the budget they gave
it so but apparently Seth macfarland
others were very keen they'd say look no
we we can dial the budget back we did it
loads lower for the first season we can
bring it back towards something like
that
um
I pretty much dropped that rumor first
it spread everywhere
um even uh JP actually repeated it on
um over Egotastic functor
um so
that we know now is true because actors
like um Adriana Palicki who who played
Billy Grayson has actually talked about
how there's been conversations that they
have in negotiations we so we know it's
been talked about
probably on pause at the moment thanks
to the right to strike
um with everything else
um what do you think about what what do
you really think the chances are
of the Orville coming back for season
four so answer your question I think
that
um from what I've seen the series
um it has certainly got a big fan base
already even though it's only been a I
think that covid has been a major aspect
which has been a problem for the series
because it was going in its big strides
and of course it was literally it's
through it made to Spanish work I
I would hope that
um it's a series itself That's Unique
enough even though it's again affiliated
with Star Treks in some ways and other
shows
um that it's got the charts of season
four it's got a great cast it is it is
it's Unique enough
that I think it would work to stand and
actually make another series I don't
know in respect of uh you only mentioned
the writer strike which is coming along
which is always started and we're
already hearing about strange new words
might be delay season three some of the
Star Wars shows
it's story this Show's canceled this
Show's canceled this Show's canceled
Roger stroke
I'm worried that if kovid was the first
kind of like dagger in the heart of the
show
then maybe the writer's strike
potentially because the final and last
dagger of a potential new season that's
what my fear is even though I'm no
expert
I I have heard rumors that there are
people
um that work closely that make these
decisions at Hulu and at Disney plus
because they they do work together
closely that wouldn't mind Seth
MacFarlane focusing on other things like
okay that they expect to be a much
bigger hit than the Orville even though
the Orville is fine it does you know
just good numbers for them and they
would rather he focused on other things
he there is maybe a plan that they can
use the right to strike as an excuse to
kill you yeah that's what I was
wondering actually
I have heard that rumor a couple of
times
um what do you think
right so I do think that the budget is
an issue
um I can tell you that I have heard a
very strong rumor recently that actually
the show is going to return for season
four
okay I brought that in the first or
second episode
um Seth MacFarlane's Gonna Leave the
series oh that's always a kiss of death
though when that happens yeah but
generally speaking so um Kelly Grayson
would become the captain
um
she kind of alluded to this in an
interview a little bit and one of the
people I speak to have said yeah that's
that looks like that's going to be the
current plan the biggest problem is Seth
MacFarlane is just too busy yeah he
can't do everything to be honest anymore
yeah he's got he's got a couple of big
movies coming up
um he's got like say the Ted TV series
coming up
um he's still obviously doing Family Guy
and American Dad he's still involved
with
um I believe American Dad still go
sh have a funny feeling you might
mention it but anyway I never really
watched it
um but he's got a lot on the go so he
he's he basically he has time to write
apparently he's a workaholic and he just
writes to like four in the morning every
night and and he has a team of people he
actually writes with and works with
actually starring in the series takes up
too much time right and being an
executive producer
um so if we get the Orville back for
season four
it might be without seven fine so how do
you feel about it if that happened would
you be all right with that
I I I I think about this in two ways
on one hand Seth macfarland isn't the
greatest actor that's ever lived I love
him and he's breaking the theories
that's his problem he was the one that
was I know you're right
but I suppose it's like when uh Richard
Dean answer left like Stargate it was
kind of like it was a different kind of
vibe when he left his seasonings
for me it didn't we could when us to do
nothing left those Target because they
brought in some good news yeah okay yeah
yeah okay yeah it was different but it
wasn't worse it was still good yeah I
agree I agree about that they would have
to bring in other other actors
um which I think is
um is I mean when Alara left they
brought in tala keali as the um is there
a replacement yeah yeah yeah yeah and I
thought that worked yeah it did work
um they're all um all of the actors that
were in the series are now out of
contract so if we do come back
we're gonna have to get them all
recontracted and so we could see a
different cast anyway so
um I could see that people might come
back for just one episode and then
something maybe catastrophic happens and
we see a different show because
left Star Trek next Generation that
would have been a huge thing if second
father's character left the oval I
should say it probably could survive
better
and I think he could they could maybe
don't kill him maybe promote him maybe
he's an admiral and you know
um O'Neill was like a general win
Seasons nine and ten and stuff like that
drop in and out when he can yeah yeah I
can see that you know so he's not he
doesn't have to film for like four
months he could just come in for a
couple of days here and there and
whatever he could probably do that he
could probably do that and that would
still be kind of like he's got like
doing his like one-liners and sort of
stuff like that and it would still kind
of work potentially so yeah I can see
that yeah so that is the rumor but
obviously as with everything at the
moment even Stargate which
we believe is sewn on to be announced at
San Diego Comic-Con We Believe
and middle of June okay so
um but with the right to strike
somebody asked me a lot for Stargate and
a couple of weeks ago I said seven
Chevrons are locked it's happening it's
I was absolutely I was 100
convinced this is going back to six now
because the writer's strike
um six Chevrons are locked now
um
just because the right to strike now
puts an element of
unknown
and I think the writer strike is going
to be used by produced by production
companies by streaming services etc etc
as um as a correction they're going to
get rid of a lot of shows and it's
already happening as I say gone deadline
show cancel show cancel show cancel
about Disney being in financial trouble
and then another Show's been canceled
you know I mean it's um they're correct
in it I think there's been there's an
element of quantity over quality in the
last couple of years in the fight to get
just stuff onto the streaming services
just material they just wanted content
and and I think
The Writer's strike will be a
will be used as a correction they need
to they need to be producing less stuff
they've been spending way too much money
they need to spend less and they need to
Simply make less stuff
and this is this is why it's going to be
a
nervous time for things like Stargate
but I actually think Stargate will
happen anyway I think they'll cancel a
bunch of stuff and then they'll announce
new things which is a fresh Dawn sort of
thing and I think Stargate will be one
of those things as someone has been
doing sci-fi podcasting on my colleague
on my show for a nearly four years the
one thing we've been saying the whole
time I I know it's slightly off topic
here is
um when is Target going to come back
um and I've watched your show and I
think you've been very informative and I
think that obviously now it's it looks
like it's gonna actually probably happen
but
My worry is with the writer strike is it
going to be the Catalyst going back to
the Orville I think the overseas of
Forbes is why we're actually here today
I'm worried about that because the
writers strike and I hope you've done
wrong
I I like you said um I like that analogy
they said that kovid was the first knife
in the belly of the covid but it
survived it can it survive a second
that's what I'm thinking about and I
think it it's it can but like I say the
conversation
might not include Seth MacFarlane well I
have to hope fingers first
we'll see what happens
right
get into the comments everybody tell us
what you think about that do you want
the Orville to return if it does return
would it be okay if Seth macfarland
wasn't involved and we did have Captain
Grayson
um
I'd love to know your thoughts get into
the comments thank you so much buddy
Michael Ball from the soul
I will drop a link to your channel in
the description guys go and have a look
it is live videos every week I I appear
in them occasionally
um and um just loads of loads of
brilliant brilliant episodes all the
time so go and check him out
just as we mentioned Stargate there will
also be a link to the Stargate petition
in the description we are asking for
Brad right to return
um in the new Stargate franchise we have
a small window of opportunity here
before this show gets announced
there are people at MGM that want Brad
Wright to be involved
so let's give them a little bit of a
nudge phone follow the link We've Got
Back 2 000 people signed up already it's
only been on there about 36 hours or
something so let's let's see if we can
push that past ten thousand
thank you very much Michael thank you
very much we will see you again sir
absolutely anytime
excellent it might be my internet but
all the way through Michael has had a
slight delay
I can see that my end I don't know why
that is I apologize
so I apologize if that's irritated
anybody but you've got me so it's fine
anyway thank you so so much sir see you
next time
foreign
[Music]